Speaker 1: Yesterday, I didn't even get to
this because we were so busy with other stories,
but this is a pretty big story.
Prosecutors in charge of the Trump criminal
probe have resigned.
They have resigned.
The Associated Press reporting the two prosecutors
in charge of the Manhattan District Attorney's
criminal investigation into Trump and his
business dealings suddenly resigned on Wednesday,
throwing the future of the probe into question
just as pressure was building on Trump.
A spokesperson for D.A.
Alvin Bragg confirmed the resignations of
Carrie Dunn and Mark Pomerantz, two top deputies
who had been tasked with running the investigation
day to day.
They started on the probe under former D.A.
Cyrus Vance and stayed on done, the office's
former general counsel argued before the Supreme
Court in a successful multiyear fight for
Trump's tax records.
Pomerantz is a former mafia prosecutor brought
out of private practice to add expertize in
white collar investigations and has been questioning
witnesses before the grand jury.
Bragg spokesperson Danielle Wilson said We
are grateful for their service and didn't
say anything else, indicating the investigation
is ongoing.
But of course, many people saying, OK, the
investigation is ongoing, but it is basically
over.
It is basically over.
And now the right is saying this is proof
the investigation was bogus.
What the right wants you to believe is that
the investigation into Trump was meritless
and bogus, and in protest, these two investigators
quit.
There is no evidence of that.
There's just no evidence of that.
What we do know with certainty is that there
is major hesitation right now from any prosecutor
to actually charge Trump.
So if we want to speculate, a much more reasonable
speculation would be the resignation is because
the investigators realize no matter what happens,
Trump's not getting charged and they were
sick of doing work that they feel will be
in vain.
Again, I'm saying, if we want to speculate,
that's way more likely that there's evidence
against Trump, and the investigators realized
this was never going to charge.
What the hell are we doing here wasting our
time?
But both are mere speculation.
We don't actually know that either of those
is the reason, and so we can only wait and
see if we get a comment.
That being said?
As I've said before, I don't think Trump's
ever going to see a day of prison, and I don't
think these resignations contradict what is
meant by my position on this for a very, very
long time years at this point.
If you disagree, let me know you can find
me on Twitter at Packman, and I want to remind
you guys, we have continued coverage of CPAC
live through the weekend through the weekend.
And on Tuesday, we will be live at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern for Joe Biden's State of the Union
address.
What will he say about 2022 election?
What will he say about the Russian invasion
of Ukraine?
What will he say in general?
We'll be live, and I hope you'll join me on
Twitter, on YouTube, Twitch and or Facebook.
We have a fantastic program for you today.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show primarily depends on
the support of our audience, viewers, listeners,
people who listen to the podcast, watch a
YouTube clip here or there.
Follow me on Tik Tok or wherever it may be.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
use the coupon code.
Wow.
22 to get a discount, remember if Alex Jones
hates the bonus show, it's probably pretty
cool.
Oh, the
Speaker 2: bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad,
Speaker 1: right?
Join Pacman Dot Com is the place to sign up.